pesto is a simple versatile sauce that's
easy to make in a food processor but
many home cooks who try and make it are
frustrated when their bright green sauce
quickly turns black like this pesto here
why does basil darken this way well when
basil is cut oxygen mixes with chemical
compounds called polyphenols which on
the surface cells of the leaf this
reaction causes the dark color and
bruised appearance the more you chop the
basil the more polyphenols you are
exposing to the oxygen and the darker it
will get and this is why pesto can turn
almost black however basil is so prone
to this enzymatic reaction that even
folding or rolling the leaves can break
enough vascular tissue and fibers on the
surface of the leaves to cause
discoloration now I've got two leaves
here to show the point this leaf here
was folded up kind of rolled up a bit
and this one is not as you can see
there's lots of dark lines where that
oxidation is already taking place
enzymes are biological agents that
increase the rate of chemical change and
not just in basil unlike many foods with
strong flavors garlic and onion have
almost no aroma in this state no one
cries when they're shopping for an onion
that sliced into that onion and the
aroma can be overpowering that's when
the tears can flow so what's happening
an enzymatic reaction similar to the
process that causes sliced basil to
darken before slicing enzymes and amino
acids are stored in separate sections of
the garlic and onion cells when the cell
walls are ruptured by a knife the
enzymes and amino acids react with each
other to create new compounds these
compounds are responsible for the
characteristic flavor of garlic and
onion in garlic odorless
sulfur-containing amino acids come into
contact with an enzyme called Alaniz the
reaction of the two eventually produces
a new compound called allicin which is
responsible for garlic's familiar scent
and flavor the more the garlic is broken
down the more flavor you get so for
example minced garlic or garlic press
through a mincer like this he's going to
have a lot more flavor
a piece of garlic that I just sliced
very thin in this garlic I'm breaking a
lot of those cells and I'm allowing a
lot of that reaction to take place here
I'm doing a much less cellular damage so
in onion the process is the same but the
compounds created are called FiOS
sultanates
unlike garlic onions also contain an
enzyme called LF synthase which is
responsible producing the tear causing
compound propane Thyle as oxide in the
test kitchen we've tried more than a
dozen purported home recipes for keeping
tears at bay everything from freezing
onions to lighting a match while we're
slicing them but the best solution is to
wear contact lenses or don a pair of ski
or swim goggles what you need is a
physical barrier to protect your eye if
you don't wear contact lenses your best
bet is a pair of goggles looks a little
bit funny but it works also using a
sharp knife with a really good edge will
inflict less cellular damage and can
actually limit production of propane
file s oxide so you want to make sure
your knife is sharp so we understand how
enzymatic reactions start but what about
stopping them one way to halt the
enzymatic reactions is with the
application of heat he activates enzymes
while at the same time transforms these
potent flavor and aroma compounds into
more pleasant forms this is what happens
when you cook sliced garlic and onions
you can also add another ingredient to
stop the reaction in the Test Kitchen we
ran a simple test with minced garlic for
a basic vinaigrette with three parts
olive oils and one part lemon juice in
one batch we added one teaspoon of
minced garlic immediately to the
dressing that's this batch here in a
second batch we soaked the minced garlic
and lemon juice for ten minutes then we
made the dressing with the garlic and
lemon juice finally in a third batch
without the grated garlic sit for 10
minutes always prepared the other
ingredients and finally mix it in with
the other ingredients so I'll be seem
like small adjustments to the order of
operations the flavor differences are
huge the citric acid in the lemon juice
speeds the conversion of that harsh
tasting Allisyn to some mellower
compounds
the same ones that are created when
garlic is heated soaking the garlic and
lemon juice was a bit more effective
than putting the garlic directly in the
dressing with all the other ingredients
but either approach is far better than
letting the minced garlic hang out for
10 minutes in that sample the garlic
flavor was overpowering and it made for
a pretty bad dressing so this is a
really simple experiment I encourage you
to try it at home really be able to
taste the difference as yourself now
what does all this have to do with pesto
well you can use heat or acidity to keep
sliced basil from changing color now you
can find a lot of recipes on the
internet that suggest throwing a vitamin
C tablet otherwise known as a sorbic
acid into the food processor with the
other ingredients I have two bowls of
pesto here that I made two hours ago the
only difference is that this one has a
thousand milligrams of vitamin C in it
as you can see it's bright green versus
the one that doesn't have any now
unfortunately you can really taste the
vitamin C and it makes the pesto kind of
unpleasantly tart so this is a really
great option but I have a third bowl of
pesto here but I also made two hours ago
now as you can see it's pretty much the
same color as the vitamin C batch now I
can tell you the big difference is that
it tastes exactly like the darkened
pesto well that's because it's made with
the identical ingredients as the dark
sample with just one change i blanched
the basil leaves and simmering water for
20 seconds before processing them with
the remaining ingredients and as I
mentioned earlier he deactivates the
enzymes that reacts with oxygen to cause
that dark color in the first place
the best part is it's completely
effective well we ran this test and
refriger the pesto for a week it was
still brilliant green the only trouble
with this technique is that you need to
bring a pot of water to a boil they need
to shock and blanch the basil a bowl of
ice water so this method makes great
sense if you're turning a bumper crop of
basil from your garden into pesto you
plan to freeze for many months but it's
a lot of work for a pesto you want to
toss with pasta tonight so I'm going to
show you a simpler way with the Test
Kitchen favorite pesto recipe